le président égyptien sadate à paris il
dîne ce soir avec le président de la
république valéry giscard d'estaing
devant 350 jeunes la jeunesse nous
apporte un témoignage d'unité
invité de notre journal jean-jacques
servan-schreiber il répond à jacques
chirac et justifie la création de l'udf
le tiercé pour gagner aujourd'hui il
fallait jouer le 4 le 11 et le 13
bonsoir et puis je vous laisse deux
secondes pour deviner de quoi je vous
parle tout de suite des vies de ce
journal top c'est fini le flocon de
neige est déjà fondu la météo bien sûr à
la une de l'actualité pendant tout ce
week end la neige le froid et le verglas
de nouzon point quitter une seule
seconde et c'est l'ouest de la france
qui a été le plus touché par ce verglas
on signale des carambolages un peu
partout et la météo pour demain et
toujours aussi pessimistes des averses
de neige et de pluie vont gagner
pratiquement l'ensemble du pays demain
le thermomètre va d'ailleurs rester aux
alentours de zéro du matin au soir
seul petit rayon de soleil sur la côte
sud-ouest ce n'est pas une consolation
mais il faut savoir que nous ne sommes
pas les seuls frappées par ces rigueurs
de l'hiver aux états unis dont on dit
souvent que c'est le pays la démesure la
tempête de neige sur la côte est en
particulier a pris des proportions
incroyables
jacquat bouchard était sur place salem
sur la côte nord-est des etats-unis fini
de se dégager à grand-peine des tonnes
de neige qui l'a submergé sur l'ordre du
président carter l'armée est intervenue
avec des moyens lourds cinq jours de
travail ont néanmoins été nécessaires
pour redonner vie à la cité l'une des
plus vieilles des états unis les
sorcières de salem c'était ici la ville
est connue à un autre titre
un habitant sur trois est d'origine
française
c'est le cas du maire michel lévêque et
de l'intérêt juin georges beauregard
dame âgée
en voici cinq ans je demeure et c'est
toute ma vie jamais que j'ai vu des
tempêtes de neige comme ça ici cet hiver
je crois que cette tempête
je ne crois pas qu'ils ont une personne
au monde aujourd'hui qui rappelle d'une
tempête chiper rossi salem a souffert
comme l'ensemble des vignes de la
nouvelle angleterre ces provinces
situées entre new york et la frontière
canadienne
mais c'est le massachussetts l'état des
kennedy et sa capitale boston qui ont
été le plus durement touché la mer s'est
déchaînée dans le port de boston au plus
fort de la tempête
le vent soufflait à près de 160 km lundi
matin était impossible de sortir de la
maison
tout au moins deux devant puisqu'il y
avait un mètre de neige devant notre
porte
vous pouvez pas forcer la porte et comme
on a un chien que c'est un problème
qu'il faut le sortir
on a on est passé par la porte de la
cave
après avoir travaillé pendant à peu près
une heure le ravitaillement alors les
trois premiers jours c'était on peut il
vous faisait la queue et parce que
forcément tout le monde était paniqué
les camions n'avaient pas pu aller dans
les magasins il n'y avait rien
maintenant c'est quand même pas c'est
plus facile on trouve à peu près tout ce
que l'on veut conséquence une semaine
après des milliers de voitures sont
toujours prises dans la neige
bien que les équipes de déblayage
travaillent 24 heures sur 24
l'état d'urgence est toujours en vigueur
à boston comme dans le reste du
massachussetts les voitures
particulières ne peuvent pas circuler
seul échappe à cette interdiction
les véhicules prioritaires ambulance ou
camions de ravitaillement les piétons
c'est à dire un million d'habitants de
boston sont toujours maîtres de la ville
où la température moyenne est de -5
degrés et à la mairie on me disait tout
à l'heure qu'il faudrait au moins deux
semaines pour que la situation
redevienne entièrement normal est de
nouveau le dispositif est d' alerte est
en place la météo est très pessimiste
pour les prochaines 48 heures elle
annonce une nouvelle une troisième
grande bourrasques de neige sur la
capitale du massachussetts les
bostoniens prennent les choses avec
philosophie
les plus sportifs utilisent comme pistes
de ski le parcours des tramways qui
traverse la ville
ils font pourtant la grimace non pas à
la perspective d'affronter un nouveau
blizzard mais parce que la facture à
payer serait particulièrement lourde
pour les contribuables du massachussetts
de trois à quatre fois plus que la
région de new york où les dommages sont
pourtant estimé à 500 millions de francs
venant de roumanie le président égyptien
sadate est arrivé cet après-midi à paris
pour une visite de 24 heures à son
programme une conférence de presse
demain matin avant de repartir pour rome
un dîner privé de travail ce soir à
l'elysée après l'entretien qu'il a eu en
fin d'après midi avec le président
giscard d'estaing paris donc avant
dernière étape de ce que les journaux
égyptiens ont appelé le pèlerinage de la
paix hier en amérique
aujourd'hui en europe paris le président
anouar el sadate est venu dire aux chefs
d'état qu'il a rencontrés ou qu'il va
rencontrer messieurs et des mois la
situation est grave
je suis dans une position très
inconfortable les négociations avec
israël n'avance pas à washington le
président anouar el-sadate n'a pas
obtenu tout ce qu'il était venu chercher
à savoir l'engagement formel la promesse
que les américains feraient pression sur
le gouvernement de monsieur begin pour
l'amener à plus de concessions sur les
territoires occupés et sur
l'implantation des colonies sauvages
dans le désert du sinaï ensuite pas de
promesses pas d'engagement non plus de
la part des américains d'une livraison
d'armes à l'armée égyptienne une armée
égyptienne qui commence à trouver son
matériel soviétique passablement démodé
et surtout inutilisable enfin le
président sadate l'a constaté lui-même
amèrement washington les états unis
restent et resteront la clé de voûte de
tout problème du conflit du proche
orient
c'est donc un président sadate toujours
détendu c'est vrai mais chaque jour un
peu plus déçu qui arrive à paris
déçu que son spectaculaire voyage à
jérusalem n'est pas encore été payés de
retour
il semble peu probable que le président
de la république française puisse
intervenir directement sur les
négociations
en revanche anouar el-sadate pourrait
obtenir des armes françaises pour
l'egypte il y a deux ans le caire a
décommandé rappelez-vous des avions
français mirage 3 et 5
aujourd'hui anouar el sadate désirent
obtenir les tout derniers mirage a faim
si que des missiles tactiques sol-sol de
fabrication franco allemand anouar el
sadate et valéry giscard d'estaing se
connaissent bien pour le président
français le raïs a fait un bilan de sa
longue tournée dans le monde
s'il n'a pas obtenu de satisfaction
concrètes et de promesses formelles
anouar el-sadate a quand même réussi à
marquer un point capital un regain de
sympathie important pour sa cause
même au sein du tout puissant lobby juif
en amérique et c'est tout dire
et oui pour l'instant pas ou peu de
résultats concrets pour le président
sadate malgré cette longue tournée
diplomatique les armes par exemple qu'il
avait permis aux américains ne lui ont
pas été accordée le président carter a
expliqué qu'il lui fallait un long
week-end de réflexion avant de présenter
un projet au congrès américain pour ses
livraisons d'armes à l'egypte un seul
sujet de satisfaction apparemment pour
le président sadate la condamnation de
l'implantation de colonies israéliennes
dans les territoires occupés cyrus vance
le secrétaire d'état américain a déclaré
que cela était contraire au droit
international
précisément vous envoyés spéciaux en
cisjordanie sont allés voir une de ses
colonies de peuplement mis en cause par
les américains une colonie qui divise
les israéliens eux mêmes
elle s'appelle shiloh c'est le nouvel an
des arbres en israël chaque année à
pareille époque les enfants s'en vont
dans tout le pays y planter des arbres
des jeunes arbres comme celui ci
pourtant ici cet événement prend une
signification particulière un peu
extraordinaire
nous sommes à shiloh qui est la dernière
en date des colonies juives en
cisjordanie
la colonie qui s'est tassée l'itie est
arrivé il y a moins de trois semaines
soit tout juste à la veille de
l'ouverture des négociations pour la
paix à jérusalem sous couvert de
recherches archéologiques
une dizaine de familles se sont
installés ici histoire de prouver et
bien que jamais il abandonnerait cette
terre qui leur appartient ça c'est ici
notre terrain c'était notre terrain
j'espère ça reste rare
et cette place était prévu déjà
longtemps
reçoit une des nouvelles colonies des
jeunes d'un des gouvernements de madame
y avait donné son accord principal est
seulement maintenant c'est devenu
faisable ne pensez pas qu'en faisant des
actes de ce type d'installation ce type
vous allez à l'encontre de la paix non
non non restera ici de toute façon et
les arabes les deux régions is as 30
personnes vivent ici dans ces roulottes
amener un beau matin dans la plus grande
discrétion en majorité des jeunes qui
ont tout abandonné pour revenir dans des
conditions difficiles jeter les bases
d'une communauté juive sur cette terre
jusque-là peuplée d'arabes palestiniens
mis devant le fait accompli le
gouvernement n'a pu faire moins que de
leur envoyé un détachement de l'armée
pour assurer leur protection et sans
doute aussi pour les surveiller cet
exemple illustre bien l'embarras du
gouvernement de menahem begin qui tout
en réaffirmant la nécessité des
implantations israéliennes
quand on pas se laisser déborder par ses
mouvements intempestifs
pour la très grande majorité est la très
grosse majorité de l'opinion publique
israélienne
c'est une erreur et ce sont des
implantations sauvages contre lesquelles
le gouverneur ne sévit pas pour des
raisons pour certaines raisons de
politique intérieure d'équilibré
c'est l'heure des semailles aussi pour
les félins cisjordanien qui retrouve à
cette occasion les gestes de leurs
ancêtres
pour eux la seule réalité c'est cette
terre où il voit s'installer depuis 11
ans des colonies israéliennes
une présence alors inacceptable et c'est
un point sur lequel leurs représentants
se refuse à toute négociation
même si c'était là la seule exigence
posée par jérusalem pour que s'instaure
la paix en cisjordanie en aucun cas nous
n'accepterons le maintien
d'implantations israéliennes sur les
territoires occupés nous savions par
avance dès 1967 que les israéliens
n'évacuaient pas d'eux mêmes ces
territoires
ils se sont installés par la force ils
repartiront par la force
ces propos intransigeant du maire de
ramallah un bastion dur ne doivent
pourtant pas dissimulé l'évolution qui
se fait jour depuis le début des
conversations israélo égyptienne c'est
ainsi qu'à l'idéologie pure certains
jeunes leaders palestiniens formés en
occident s'efforce de substituer la
diplomatie des mots est d'accord avec
l'idée d'autonomie proposé par le
gouvernement israélien
mais à condition qu'elle s'applique à
tous les palestiniens et pas seulement à
ceux qui vivent en cisjordanie en ce
moment nous serons alors convaincu
qu'israël est prêt à nous reconnaître en
tant que peuple car si nous bénéficions
d'une autonomie sous cette forme
nous serons alors libre de faire venir
nos représentants c'est-à-dire l'ol
peine car l'autonomie sans l'ol paie ne
peut en aucun cas nous préparer à une
future indépendance
cela c'est peut-être pour demain en
attendant le problème des implantations
demeure un exemple voici phare qaddoum
villages arabes à quelques centaines de
mètres voilà marc année qaddoum villages
israéliens une colonie sauvage a planté
dans un ancien camp militaire de village
qui porte le même nom et se font face
depuis des mois sans le moindre contact
en somalie depuis la nuit dernière
mobilisation générale est à d'urgence et
envoi de troupes régulières en ogaden la
région située à l'est de l'ethiopie
selon un hebdomadaire britannique le
sunday telegraph les états unis
préparent un pont aérien pour livrer des
armes à la somalie en cas d'invasion
éthiopienne et puis le grand point
d'interrogation du week-end place et
après cette question y aura-t-il une
réunion des ministres des finances
américain anglais allemand japonais et
français aujourd'hui à paris ce point
d'interrogation peut disparaître
apparemment r&d claude la réunion a bien
lieu et elle se tient même à versailles
dégoûté oui outre que le pavillon où ils
se réunissent d'habitude à versailles
était très bien gardé cet après midi
outre cela il ya tout un faisceau de
présomptions qui semble indiquer que la
réunion a bien eu lieu
alors ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à londres
et à washington par exemple on admet la
présence en france aujourd'hui du
chancelier anglais de l'échiquier
monsieur riz lait et aussi du secrétaire
d'état au trésor
monsieur blumentahl sûr aussi les
ministres des finances des cinq
principaux pays occidentaux je voulais
rappelle états unis grands
rob bagg allemagne japon et france
féminine se voir régulièrement
la dernière fois c'était en décembre en
france donc pourquoi pas en ce moment où
justement ils ont pas mal de choses à se
dire alors de quoi justement à va-t-il
parler et bien écoutez style se sont
bien rencontrés ils ont évoqué sûrement
au moins deux problèmes d'abord
l'instabilité actuelle du marché des
changes à peu près sûr toutes les
monnaies notamment sur la couronne
norvégienne et sur le dollar
et puis bien sûr la mauvaise santé du
franc qui je vous le rappelle a perdu un
peu de sa valeur toute la semaine
dernière est ce qu'on peut dire en tout
cas c'est que cette réunion si elle a eu
lieu est vraisemblablement à
l'initiative de la france puisqu'elle se
tient à paris cette réunion dans la
droite ligne de ce que le président de
la république avait demandé la semaine
dernière monsieur bart c'est à dire tout
mettre en oeuvre pour soutenir le franc
or une réunion des cinq par ses
décisions mais aussi par son impact
psychologique
une telle réunion a de bonnes chances de
décourager les spéculateurs et donc de
stabiliser les menus j - 28 pour les
élections législatives il y à quelques
minutes au club de la presse de europe 1
georges séguy a affirmé qu'en cas
d'échec de la gauche à ces élections
il faut s'attendre à une période de
tensions sociales sûrement très aigu et
puis ici à propos de son appel public à
voter communiste le secrétaire général
de la cgt a expliqué qu'il y avait déjà
eu des précédents benoît frachon avait
fait pour maurice thorez par exemple je
ne suis pas un syndiqué diminué a dit
georges sic
deux sondages dans les hebdomadaires de
ce week-end la boussole sofres du nouvel
observateur 45% des français estiment
que le rapport des forces évolué en
faveur de la gauche
le dernier sondage ifop publié par le
point montre que 52% des intentions de
vote vont à lo position 44% à la
majorité ce sont des résultats
circonscription par circonscription
et puis toujours à propos de ces
élections c'est demain lundi que s'ouvre
le délai de sept jours fixé par le code
électoral pour le dépôt des candidatures
vous savez que l'on votait aujourd'hui
et oui élections municipales second tour
à issy les moulineaux
dimanche dernier c'est la liste d'union
de la gauche qui était arrivé en tête
peut-être les résultats définitifs de
cette élection dans le dernier journal
d'hervé claude ce soir et puis politique
encore avec monsieur jean-jacques
servan-schreiber invité de notre journal
monsieur le président du parti radical
bonsoir valéry giscard d'estaing a
expliqué qu'il y avait deux tendances
dans la majorité ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine
le meeting rpr de la porte de pantin
l'intervention de jacques chirac dans
cartes sur table disons que l'udf était
un phénomène sans importance peut
laisser penser qu'il y a dans cette
majorité une tendance majeure est une
tendance mineurs non je crois que ce
dernier épisode cet accès d'humeur et la
fin d'une bataille secondaire et que
nous entrons partir d'aujourd'hui nous
sommes à un mois
ce soir du vote des français dans la
bataille essentielle
alors comment classer ce que vous venez
d'indiquer c'est à dire le phénomène
union pour la démocratie française
c'est la stratégie du président récuse
tout aussi nette que ça et c'est sa
stratégie depuis le début je dirais pour
être clair qu'en mai 74
quand il a été élu président de la
république contre le candidat de lumière
et contre le candidat du programme comme
il était sur une ligne de crête très
difficile et qu'il n'a gagné que la
moitié de la partie et qu'il a été du
président de la république en 74 mais
que depuis maintenant bientôt quatre ans
qu'il n'avait pas avec lui le parlement
le parlement continue à être dominée par
une autre force politique que celle de
monsieur giscard d'estaing et de la
volonté de réforme de la démocratie
française
autrement dit monsieur giscard d'estaing
gagné la première manche en 74
reste à gagner la deuxième manche et
c'est maintenant il faut donc de nous
est maintenant dans un mois il gagne et
contre les forces du passé est contre
mais ce marché mitterrand sa deuxième
manche pour avoir enfin le pouvoir
présidentiel et parlementaire de
réaliser son entreprise pour la france à
laquelle je crois et qu'il a appelé
lui-même démocratie française pas ce qui
s'est passé c'est que le coup d'envoi a
été donné par lui-même comme prévu à
verdun sur le doubs ya maintenant une
quinzaine de jours lorsqu'il a dit
clairement et solennellement il ya deux
courants dans la majorité présidentielle
le courant de la continuité et le
courant de la réforme et j'ai répondu de
nancy le lendemain vers notre accord sur
la création de ce
courant de ce mouvement qui l'union pour
la démocratie française et notre accord
sur l'unité d'action au deuxième tour
des élections
monsieur monsieur servan-schreiber vous
dit le président en est l'inspirateur il
faut tout de même un chef d'orchestre
alors qui est le patron en attendant la
démocratie française n'a pas de patron
est là un hôte un auteur le voyez voilà
c'est clair et sain mais sur le terrain
ne croyait pas ou ne croyez pas qu'on
appelle un mouvement union pour la
démocratie française sans l'accord de
l'auteur oui nous bien sûr tout est
clair et simple
monsieur giscard d'estaing a des alliés
politiques
et puis la save son inspiration
personnelle sa conviction profonde qui
est ce qu'il a exprimé lui-même dans un
livre qui a pris le mal d'écrire qui est
la démocratie française
l'auteur c'est monsieur giscard oui mais
le président ne peut pas être le patron
de l'udf en entier le patron de l'udf il
n'y a pas de patron et un aspirateur qui
est l'auteur de démocratie française et
puis à les responsables politiques qui
sont ceux qui se sont réunis qui se sont
unifiés avec un gros effort régulier
permanent systématique dans l'union pour
la démocratie française qui maintenant
efface les anciens partis politiques
pour la campagne des quatre semaines qui
restent
il ya donc les deux courants de la
majorité c'est clair et net il ya le rpr
il ya l'udf l'union pour la démocratie
française et qui sont d'ailleurs l'année
note en dessous de ce qu'il devrait être
et de ceux qui devront être s'il faut
gagner
comme l'a dit monsieur giscard d'estaing
dans son discours d'ailleurs il a dit
faut que les deux courants s'identifie
et progresse l'un et l'autre
aujourd'hui tout le monde le sait vous
connaissez pas l'ordre de grandeur lui
refaire à environ 21% d'intentions de
vote
l'udf environ 24% d'intentions de vote
ce qui fait 45 qui fait la défaite
il faut donc quand quatre semaines leurs
pires progresse et que l'edf ogresse son
instant vous pensez on gagne et alité la
perte des élections non je dis que s'ils
ont voté ce soir
sur le papier la majorité présidentielle
perdrait les élections 24% pour l'udf
21% pour les bears fait 45 et jeudi
qu'il reste quatre semaines grâce au
fait de cette clarification entre le rpr
et de l'udf entre les deux courants que
le présent à public a appelé de ses
voeux et que nous avons réalisés en
quatre jours et qui est maintenant dans
dix
jour et 410 candidats et des avons une
chance de progresser grâce à cette
dialectique entre ces deux courants de
même que monsieur marchais mitterrand
progressé grâce au fait qu'ils étaient
parallèle et distincts vous croyez que
c'est clair pour les électeurs et que
par la réforme vous pourrez décrocher
une partie de l'électorat qui est allé
chez les socialistes
pas forcément conviction tout à fait et
depuis le début c'est pourquoi j'ai
refusé personnellement depuis le mois de
juillet la malle guerre militaire
car comme l'a dit monsieur giscard
d'estaing de nouveau je suis en accord
complet avec lui sur ses stratégies
depuis le début il a dit l'uniformité de
la majorité je le cite c'est l'échec de
la majorité présidentielle donc depuis
le 19 juillet comme vous le savez j'ai
refusé de signer ce qu'on a fait le
pacte unitaire parce que l'uniformité
c'est l'échec à partir de monsieur
giscard d'estaing consac solennellement
la nécessité d'avoir deux courants
distincts dont l'un pour la réforme qui
va dire l'udf
je crois qu'il ya une chance sérieuse de
gagner en quatre semaines les quatre ou
cinq points qu'il faut gagner et au
deuxième tour monsieur jacques servan je
sais bien que va-t-il se passer est ce
que l'udf a par exemple appelé à voter
pour le candidat rpr le mieux placé mais
tout ça est clair et net et j'ai dit
clairement à l'appel du président le
lendemain même de son discours qu'il n'y
avait plus aucun problème que le
deuxième tour il n'y aurait qu'un
candidat de majorité présidentielle face
au candidat de l'opposition
si vous gagnez ce ne sera pas l'état udf
oui vous avez un mac inventé le slogan
vous voulez taïder on vous le retourne
sous une autre autoroute c'est assez
drôle mais c'est impossible
d'abord parce que l'esprit démocratique
du printemps un public et si je peux me
permettre
celui de ceux qui le suivent et
soutiennent nous interdirait de faire un
état qui ressemble à ce que j'avais dit
qu'il est a u dire c'est à dire quoi la
confusion entre le pouvoir politique et
le pouvoir
c'est contraire à tout le livre de
monsieur giscard d'estaing démocratie
française c'est contré en ma conviction
dans le manifeste radical identique donc
il n'y aura pas d'état et des f mais
j'espère bien que l'auteur de démocratie
française aura le pouvoir à partir
d'avril à partir d'avril maintenant à la
présidence et au parlement de mettre
enfin la france à l'heure de son temps
merci monsieur servan-schreiber
je rappelle les deux grands
et vous politique que vous fixe antenne
2 dans les jours prochains demain lundi
à 20h30 spécial élections raymond barre
interrogé par jean-pierre elkabbach et
alain duhamel mercredi à 20h30 également
cartes sur table avec françois
mitterrand
les lycéens de la zone à vont retarder
leurs vacances de quelques heures pour
venir à l'elysée ce matin il faisait
partie des 350 jeunes qui sont venus
présenter au président de la république
le bilan de la consultation nationale
organisée par le secrétariat à la
jeunesse et aux sports
un bilan en forme de portrait de la
jeunesse française à porter qui a étonné
quelque peu le chef de l'état valéry
giscard d'estaing soulignant notamment
que la jeunesse était finalement moins
sombre pour le disait souvent et qu'elle
était un témoignage d'unité
oui un portrait étonnant des jeunes
français ressort de cette consultation
les jeunes sont heureux ont des rapports
confiant avec leurs parents y croient en
leur avenir se sentent libres et
responsables et les contestataires me
direz vous certes il en existe mais ils
sont paraît-il très minoritaires les
jeunes français sont de plus généreux
ils veulent s'engager et servir
ils sont contre le racisme les kft
l'égoïsme leur désire améliorer la
qualité de la vie le président de la
république s'est dit surpris
agréablement par cet autoportrait de la
jeunesse ces jeunes at il précisé
apportent à leurs aînés un témoignage
d'unité
monsieur giscard d'estaing a promis à
tous les jeunes qu'ils répondraient à
leurs aspirations c'est à dire avoir un
emploi où ils se sentent libres et en
sécurité
il a annoncé une amélioration de
l'articulation entre l'éducation et
l'emploi et un développement de la
formation permanente
je le dis donc sans emphase mais avec
force la france peut être fière de la
jeunesse qu'elle a aujourd'hui
et je dirais c'est le résultat le plus
frappant le plus encourageant de cet
autoportrait et c'est pour moi la
première conclusion de cette
consultation
vous devez ensuite qu'en tant que chef
de l'état
les responsabilités particulières qui
sont les miennes et dont vous imaginez
bien entendu l'étendue et le poids je
retire de cette consultation un puissant
encouragement puissant encouragement à
persévérer dans les directions que je me
suis fixé le constate en effet au
travers de la consultation que le type
de société auxquels notre jeunesse
aspire est bien celle que je m'efforce
de bâti et que les changements que la
jeunesse réclame son bien ce que je
m'efforce de conduits il se trouve que
votre rôle est le mien c'est de regarder
vers l'avenir
parce que vous comme moi nous avons le
temps avec nous vous à cause de votre
âge et moi à cause de ma fonction je
rappelle rapidement les deux résultats
du championnat de france de football de
première division i les deux matchs cet
après-midi en effet reims et marseille
ont fait match nul 0 à 0
lyon a battu le paris saint germain 3 2
à paris monaco donc est en tête du
classement et puis il y avait un tiercé
cet après midi à vincennes
quatorze chevaux étaient au départ du
prix de châteaudun couru sur 2600 mètres
fait varon le 13 entre dans la ligne
droite suivi de fabry noé gras sus des
profitant de la faute du cheval de tête
ils vont atteindre le poteau ensemble la
photo va donner la victoire à gracious
leucate résultats dont 4 11 et 13
un tiercé qui rapporte donc dans l'ordre
pour 5 francs 5322 francs 50 centimes et
dans un ordre différent 1064 franck et
50 centimes
4 11 13
et puis une demi heure plus tard c'était
le prix de paris la troisième grande
course internationale m'a expliqué
claude ruben une épreuve d'endurance
3150 mètres à parcourir et les hazard en
tête à la sortie du dernier virage ne
sera plus rejoint malgré le rush final
de grandpré son principal rival peut
admirer les ans de ce champion que drive
léopold verroken cheval était mourant
l'année dernière bravo donc eleazar pour
terminer ce journal
honneur à la grande triomphatrice d'hier
soir sur antenne 2 je sais que vous êtes
des millions avoir suivi la finale des
chiffres et des lettres en direct de
monter car et c'est madame simone
menesguen de lorient qui a gagné
brillamment b en battant michel pialat
mais avant de vous demander vos secrets
mais la menace guen je vous propose de
remonter le temps un peu et de revenir
au tournant de la partie le score à ce
moment là hier soir était de 102 à 112
regardez bien consommée elle consomme
moyenne à noyelles aux moyennes moyennes
y consomme j
5 la menace il est loyal royal
voilà royal et vous avez désigné
lesbiennes de soirée était royale je me
suis regardé d'ailleurs avec un plaisir
immense parce que j'aurais bien voulu
revoir ce match je les ai vécues mais je
ne sais même pas comment je les ai vécu
parce que vous avez eu le trac hier soir
oui le trac mais je n'avais pas peur
d'attraper l'impression vous avez
beaucoup de sang froid
oui je pense d'ailleurs il en faut
énormément jeu fera partager et je crois
que vous allez avoir besoin de garder la
tête froide maintenant parce que si j'en
juge par ce qu'il se passe et ce que
vous me racontez dans le métro au
passage de police de l'avion vous êtes
devenu une star
j'en suis tout étonné vicieux racontez
moi un petit peu c'est bien c'est vrai
les gens me reconnaissent notre bord je
suis qui est agréable c'est que c'est
toujours très gentil très sympathie et
ils me disent merci
moi je dis merci aussi c'est très bien
c'est très très chaleureux surtout pièce
quand vous demande vos secrets parce que
vous devez avoir des petits sauts
craquante ou un peu comme tous les
autres candidats je suppose au départ un
penchant pour ce genre de jeu que l'on
cultive évidemment par la suite avec une
érudition que l'on acquiert aussi vous
avez un entraînement particulier où je
suivais a non seulement au départ
j'aimais beaucoup les mots croisés après
ce jeu mar le passionné des le d'emblée
alors je me suis dit si je veux y aller
réussir quelque chose eh bien il faut
améliorer parce que j'avais beaucoup
beaucoup de faiblesses vous feuilletez
luc-sur-mer régulièrement quand je
feuillette oui sanary de le feuilleter
mais pas systématiquement le campus
entraînements par jour assure dans les
pages ainsi sa mort je regarde
l'émission tout le temps je crois qu'il
faudrait au moins un tremblement de
terre pour que je ne la regarde pas
c'est très bien pour antenne de la fst
meilleur entraînement mais il faut
encore autre chose certainement et
comment faites vous vous choisissez les
voyelles d'abord on s'en est aperçu
mais est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose de
systématique au moment du choix après
les consonnes
lorsque je demande dans le jeu oui eh
bien non je demande systématiquement 4
voyelles quatre consonnes dans un ordre
qui est souvent le même d'ailleurs je me
réserve par exemple si j'avais quatre
consonnes sans eux vous réserve quand
même la possibilité d'en demander une
cinquième mais en principe comme j'aime
le jeu j'adore jouer je n'aime pas à
combiner et je préfère jouer avec ce
qu'ils me ce qui me choix si vous aviez
un conseil à donner à ceux qui ceux qui
veulent jouer aux chiffres et aux
lettres vous le champion
je dirais bien sûr il faut s'entraîner
mais énormément de maîtrise de soi alors
à jeu processus argent vous l'avez fait
prendre merci l'amérique retrouverez
hervé claude vers 22h 24 exactement à
22h24 d'ailleurs pour la dernière
édition
je souhaite une très belle soirée sur
antenne 2